en matière de cinéma aussi le Val de
Loire Excel d'abord publicité grâce à
ces châteaux on peut citer par exemple
la série de serpent Queen tournée à
Chambord Amboise ou Chenonceau mais la
région est aussi une perte d'accueil
pour les films d'animation 3 soutenus
par l'agence cyclique avant dôme ont
reçu un weekend un César coûte
projecteur sur la vie sexuelle de Mamie
avec Aurélie Renaud
le désir l'orgasme les souvenirs intimes
d'une grand-mère racontée dans ce film
d'animation sur le statut des femmes
slovennes au début du 20e siècle ou
quand les femmes étaient perçues comme
des objets dédiés à satisfaire leur
époux 13 minutes de films et un César
celui du meilleur court-métrage
d'animation un film produit par une
société tout rangelle ça prime ce film
là en particulier bien sûr mais c'est la
représente aussi toutes ces années où on
donne tout pour faire des films parce
que l'animation ça reste quand même un
tout petit milieu quoi le film est né
ici à Vendôme dans les studios de
cycliques animations les deux
co-réalisatrices ont été accueillis en
résidence durant quatre mois pour
fabriquer les dessins matériels
digital les studios étaient alors
disposition
Emily Pigeard désormais césarisé avait
choisi un style enfantin pour parler
sexualité j'utilise de encres et des
crayons de couleurs qui sont durs mais
voilà qu'il va essayer d'expliquer cette
cette thématique de la sexualité des
femmes voilà j'aurais jamais imaginé
dans ma vie d'avoir un César c'est même
quand on me faisait le film avec ma
coralisatrice on avait aucune idée enfin
qu'il allait aussi loin et qu'on allait
vivre toute cette expérience après donc
non non c'est c'est des sentiments qui
sont qui sont incroyables un César et un
pari gagné pour cyclique l'agence
régionale pour l'image présidée par
Julie Gayet évidemment sur le territoire
on accueille les tournages et que c'est
formidable c'est grâce à Vendôme et à
cette résidence que les jeunes créateurs
de demain les jeunes réalisatrices en
plus de de d'animation peuvent financer
plus tard leur premier long-métrage qui
sont budget colossaux j'aimerais que
tous les gens de la région Centre Val de
Loire sachent à quel point vraiment
cyclique fait ce travail qui rayonne à
l'international dans nos industries
soutenu à l'écriture par cyclique saint
Homère d'Alice Diop reçoit le César du
meilleur premier film